bonjour bienvenue avec mon sur arte
france alors on a vu certains médias qui
tu es qui titrait un précisément les
restaurateurs remportent leur combat
est-ce que selon vous c'est une victoire
face à axa oui bonjour c'est une avancée
c'est incontestable que c'est une
avancée
c'est encore une victoire totale parce
que les propositions qui sont faites par
l'assureur sont encore insuffisantes et
ne couvre pas les pertes d'exploitation
qui ont été subies par les restaurateurs
durant la période du coc vide qui sont
très importants qu'il faut quand même
savoir que les restaurateurs ont eux
sont restés pratiquement fermé pendant
un an
durant cette crise sanitaire on est
d'accord 1 300 millions d'euros pour
15mhz une restaurateurs ses réponses
seulement une partie des pertes dues à
la crise sanitaire
dans ce contexte bref on peut parler
d'un arrangement alors accès a présenté
sa commune une offre de transaction en
deux mots l'assureur vous dit j'ai perdu
mes procès parce qu'il faut que vous
sachiez que 80% des juridictions qui
sont saisies du contentieux condamne
l'assureur indemniser le restaurateur
j'accepte effectivement d'indemniser
mais pas dans le cadre des garanties que
j'ai faits dont j'ai fait bénéficier
mais mais assuré lord a soumis une
signature du contrat
l'offre authier présenté par par axa est
de l'ordre d'un tiers du montant des
sommes qui deux pour être versé aux
restaurateurs
ainsi le restaurateur acceptent cette
offre 7 ça on est d'accord qu'il ne
pourra plus retourner en justice
c'est le principe de la transaction vous
recevez l'offre d'axa vous signer un
document en vertu duquel vous renoncer à
toute action pour l'avenir c'est donc
encore une fois une avancée pour les
restaurateurs
mais je les incite en ce qui me concerne
allez voir leurs avocats et à négocier
avec avec d'assureurs
le montant des garanties qui seraient
susceptibles d'être versée dans le cas
de cette transaction
et est ce que vous êtes au courant du
calendrier à partir de quelle date le
premier restaurateur va commencer à être
indemnisés si on veut parler réalisation
alors je peux vous dire que les agents
généraux d'axa téléphone à tous les
assurés actuellement leurs disons vous
avez deux mois pour accepter la
transaction et au mois de septembre ça
sera fini maintenant j'ai pas plus de
détails parce que l'annoncé officielle a
été faite hier matin et les avocats dax
1 n'ont pas encore approché les avocats
des restaurateurs pour le moment ça se
passe dans le cadre du réseau des agents
généraux axa qui téléphone directement
leurs assurés en en faisant des
propositions qui n'apparaissent
nettement insuffisant alors le directeur
général du groupe axa a parlé d'un de
regretter un il a dit qu'il regrettait
ce malentendu
comment peut-on parler de malentendu sur
les conditions d'indemnisation par
rapport à une assurance ça veut dire
quoi
les contrats n'étaient pas assez clair
ce que ce cas que ça appelle un
malentendu c'est ni plus ni moins que
les conséquences d'une mauvaise
rédaction d'un contrat pour être soit de
synthétique sur le sur le problème
juridique qui oppose les restaurateurs
axa il faut savoir qu axa dont ces
contrats vendée une garantie perte
d'exploitation pour épidémies et que
parallèlement dans ces contrats figure
et une clause d'exclusion qui indiquait
que la garantie n'était pas due si un
autre établissement était couché pour
épidémie dans le département ce qui a
est apparu à tous les tribunaux à la
majorité des tribunaux tout à fait
contradictoires
on ne peut pas par une clause vidé de sa
substance la garantie principale on peut
pas garantir pour épidémie d'un côté et
en même temps dire cette épidémie il va
falloir qu'elle soit localisé à votre
seul établissement
on n'a jamais vu une épidémie qui est
localisé en restaurant ou un bar que le
bar à côté n'ai pas touché ou le
resteront en côte est n'est pas couché
merci jean pierre tation d'avoir été
avec nous sur arte france et d'avoir
répondu à la question
à pâques vous êtes avocat au barreau de
marseille mercière